hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm gonna
answer questions from one of my Facebook
readers in the Dean who wrote insane
hello
I don't know what to do because my
family doesn't approve of me becoming an
entrepreneur and taking risks can I have
some advice so thanks for the question a
Dean really started to hear about that
situation and it's actually quite common
in general you know the safe way to live
your life is to go to school get your
first job become an accountant or a
doctor or lawyer and you know go through
that path and I think the world kind of
leads us towards those paths and it can
be tough when everyone around you is on
that path and it's hard to break free in
terms of what to do with your parents my
suggestion would be to start small so
you know you don't want to risk that
relationship and what I would try to do
is build your business up on the side
part-time I don't know if you're going
to school or not or if you're in the
workforce or not but start by
moonlighting separates or something
small on the side build up something to
first see if you like it right see if
you like being an entrepreneur because
it's hard and it sounds exciting but
once you're into it the glamour kind of
goes away and you're you're stuck
running this business so make sure
something you really like and a great
way to do it is to start part-time see
if you can start making some money on it
see if you if you find value in it see
if you're helping people see if you're
getting good feedback from people and
see if it's something you want to
continue doing or not and I think at
least with some parents if they see that
you're really excited about something
and that you're helping people it's
easier to to get their approval and they
get them to say yes you know I don't
know how helpful they'll be ongoing but
that part is a little easier you know
one one common thing about parents is
they want to see their kids happy and
successful and so they're I'm sure
worried about you that you're gonna not
be successful with your business and not
be able to you know have your your place
I guess in society so seeing that you
are happy
that you are helping people even if it's
not making a lot of money yet that's a
good start so that's what I would do at
the beginning as it starts to grow and
you think you're getting you know
there's something you want to continue
doing and you're getting a lot of fun
out of it you get a lot of value helping
a lot of people with it I try to
negotiate something so a great example
is with Michael Dell so if you look at
Dell store we have on the website but
long story short he was a university
student I think as University of Austin
and he started his his business making
these computers in his dorm room and it
was growing and became you know he
needed to expand beyond it and it
started getting in the way of his
studies and his parents wanted him to
continue on and I think become a doctor
and he made a deal with them to say
listen I know you want me to go and
finish school and you know become the
doctor and finished my education but I
really want to be an entrepreneur and
here's my proposal to you I'm gonna take
one summer I'm gonna take the next
summer off I'm not gonna do an
internship I'm not gonna you know go get
a job I'm gonna take the summer off and
I'm gonna work on my business and if I
can grow it to the point where can
sustain myself and keep it going then
I'm gonna run that business and not go
back to school and so it was a trial so
it's easier for them to say yes to
something on a small scale and see if it
works and if you can come back with data
to say hey look we're growing I'm making
money I'm adding a lot of value I'm a
positive member of this of our community
in society then it's easier to get their
approval and to keep going and to you
know continue to build this business I
know it's still tough and at the end of
the day if you really want to do it and
they don't want you to do it you have to
make that decision and figure out how
much is that going to impact your
relationship with them and how important
is it versus starting your own business
you know at the end of the day most
parents love their kids and want to see
them be successful even if it goes
against what they originally had in mind
you know I think a lot of parents have
have a game plan for their kids and they
almost never follow it so again what I
would start doing is start part time
continue the path you're on but start
part time see if you like it
see if you're able to help people make
some money if you're able to get it to a
certain point where you think this could
really take off they're trying to
negotiate a little bit of time off if
it's the summer or half a year or
whatever it is focus on building your
business and then you know if you're
able to achieve that success keep on
going in my own case this is a quick
example I went to university I finished
my degree undergrad Bachelor of Commerce
at University of Toronto I started my
business the first one when I was in
university so I was in third year
university and when I graduated I had
job offers and successful companies and
you know banks investment banks and
salting companies and they were
interesting you know and it's it's
seductive it's what all my friends were
doing at the time were in the university
in my classes with me and I thought once
I get on that treadmill it's really hard
to get off you know if you're 40 years
old or 50 years old and you've been
doing this for a while
it's really really hard to jump off that
corporate treadmill and do your own
thing the risks are a lot higher if you
have a family and kids and so on and so
that I thought to myself at least the
time to do this is now and I told myself
and luckily my parents were very I had
their support I didn't have to worry
about that it was more what I wanted to
do and I told myself I'm gonna take a
year and try this thing and if I can't
make it work then I can always go back
at those jobs again in a year but I'm
gonna take a year and try it out and see
what I can make of it and I took that
year and I never went back so that's my
recommendation to you so hopefully this
helped for those of you watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below always gives me more motivation
and encouragement to do more videos for
you and I'd love to hear we have to
think if you wanna leave a comment below
comment about this video or give a
question about your own company or
business I'd love to try to answer it
for you I always read those and I
appreciate them when I when they come in
so thank you and we'll see you on the
next episode
you